hello everyone apologies for the delay I
hope this is all working I'm taking
questions from patreon people today so
there's 841 questions ready to go so
hopefully I'm up to this
what should teaching and research in the
humanities look like I'm going to grad
school for literature and I don't want
my work to serve ideological possession
well the thing is first of all is that
you kind of have to educate yourself
when you go to graduate school you know
you have your courses but I don't think
that you learn more than about 10% of
what graduate school can teach you by
taking the courses you have to read and
the mistake that most people read is
make is that they only read what's being
published in the last five or six years
in their own narrow field and that's
increasingly a bad idea
the libraries are full of classic books
and I would say take your field go back
to the beginning of the field at least
read the people who wrote the classic
works bring yourself up to date and then
familiarize yourself with as much
history as much history of art as much
history of literature and literature as
you can possibly manage you want to
learn as much as you can about
everything I would also say you have two
li that with a certain degree of
specialization you have to pick one
topic and really become expert at it but
it'll serve as a doorway to because
everything's connected it'll serve as a
doorway to what's behind it so you focus
on one thing and read as much as you can
on that that's your specific discipline
then outside of that read as widely as
you possibly can manage the other thing
I would really recommend and this is
also true if you're going to university
is it isn't enough to read you also have
to write and if you're gonna go to
graduate school you should write
everyday it's a good idea for anyone who
wants to develop themselves
intellectually but even half an hour a
day you know that's a hundred and eighty
hours a year that's a lot of thinking
because writing is thinking and you
should be writing out your understanding
of what you wrote or what you read and
the questions you have about it and
trying to formulate what you regard as
clear questions and problems and also
clear answers both of those and that's
how I would say you should approach
graduate school have you thought about
slowing down there are people worried
about how hard you're pushing yourself
with
the countless commitments yes well I
would say that those people worried
about that include I don't know if it's
me but certainly my family they're
worried about it but I'm putting
competent people around me increasingly
to handle the scheduling of the public
events for example and I have good
agents and a good publisher and I'm
learning how to manage this I think I've
I'm not really interested I suppose and
slowing down although it has been a bit
much in the last year and a half I I do
better in some ways when I'm working
flat out if my health was good it's
better than it was by a large margin and
maybe it's still getting better if my
health was good this none of this would
be an overwhelming challenge but I'm
trying to do everything I can to put my
health in order and many many things
have been fixed so yeah I thought about
slowing down but I've decided against it
I guess is really the final answer to
that that's the other thing you know
there are times in your life where it's
not time to slow down it's time to
become more efficient that's the thing
you can become so efficient you know you
end up doing things in five minutes that
would otherwise take you a week might
that might seem like an exaggeration but
and I suppose it is to some degree but
it's not that much of an exaggeration so
as you take on more responsibilities and
you determine that you're going to
become more efficient the responsibility
pushes the efficiency so what do they
say - there's time enough to sleep when
you're in the grave
many who respect your work feel your
tweets are often impulsive or even
expedient very funny in certain
interactions would you consider a change
in the way you tweet well I've been
considering that for a very long time
one of the things I did in the last
month which that I think was productive
Twitter's a hard dishearten to manage
because it rewards impulsivity and I
have somewhat of a temper and I suspect
that it's maybe I'm more susceptible to
being to being tempted to respond in a
too forceful manner maybe I'm more
tempted by that then I should be but
Twitter is really useful I mean it does
keep me updated with regards to the
ongoing let's say war that's raging at
the bottom of our culture and it doesn't
able me to stay in contact with people
at least to some degree and it's a great
way of communicating small but at least
in principle important ideas and also to
let people know about what I'm doing on
YouTube and with the tours and and all
of that people seem to respond
positively to those sorts of
notifications so what I did do in the
last month was to find people I tweeted
out one day I asked people to send me
the Twitter handles of organizations or
individuals who were reporting on
positive developments in a credible and
realistic way human progress org seems
to be doing that really well I thought
it would be good to tilt my Twitter feed
toward or to my Twitter actions towards
things that are positive and also true
as much as possible and so I've started
doing that in the last month I feel
somewhat of an obligation
- if I'm being discussed publicly by
journalists or or other professors and
they misrepresent me or misrepresent the
ideas that they're purporting to discuss
then I feel like I have a moral
obligation - I suppose one is to defend
myself I suppose and certainly to object
to the MIS utilization of ideas by my
fellow academics I don't know if that's
uh I don't know if that's reasonable or
not it's not easy to figure out in a
situation like this how much you shut up
how much you stay patient how much you
push back how much you fight how how
firmly you respond whether or not to use
wit I mean the rule I tried to outline
in in my book twelve rules for life
there's a chapter called don't let your
children do anything that makes you
dislike them and there's a philosophy of
discipline in there and and it really
has two dimensions let's say or two it's
it's at the juncture of two ideas one
idea is that you don't want to make any
more rules than necessary because you
get tangled up in them so minimum
necessary rules that's a good guideline
for setting up any structure even in
dealing with yourself and then if you're
going to have rules you have to enforce
them because otherwise they're not rules
and so how do you enforce them with
minimal necessary force and some of that
has to be played with you know and
experimented with so you know at minimal
force is those are really good
principles and I try to govern myself by
them in my Twitter behavior but and I
hope that that's successful
you know sometimes when I've gone after
people I went after a couple of
journalists in Canada last year who
wrote I would what I would regard as
scurrilous and incompetent articles
that's a bad combination and you know it
was kind of a harsh exchange I would say
but it isn't clear that it was the wrong
thing to do
so it's hard to know how much you have
to skirt the ragged edge of disaster if
you want to do things right so anyways I
am changing the way I tweet because I'm
trying to make it the bulk of it
informative and positive I guess I
should say something about that too you
know there's a lot of really good things
going on in the world so we have poverty
absolute poverty between the year 2000
and 2012 which was three years ahead of
what the UN had hoped would happen you
know in cynics say well you have
absolute poverty and but the cutoff was
kind of arbitrary it was a dollar ninety
a day if I remember correctly which
obviously is quite low so it's not a
real transformation it's like it's a
real transformation some number had to
be picked to represent absolute poverty
and I don't suspect the UN erred on the
side of capitalist over optimism perhaps
they did but hundreds of thousands of
people are being connected to the power
grid every day fresh waters available
not to fewer and fewer people but to
more and more people and that's
happening extremely rapid rapidly no
starvation in India and China is a thing
completely of the past you never hear
about that and that's pretty much the
case for the rest of the world except
now and then for political reasons so
you know everybody's got a cell phone or
an and anybody who doesn't is gonna have
one in the next 10 years and that puts
in people's hands a degree of
communication and access that would have
been absolutely incomprehensible even 15
years ago
so it seems to me that the reason to
that I changed it seemed to me that it
was worthwhile to change the way that I
was using Twitter because all these good
things are happening and just
concentrating on this polarization
process that seems to have gripped us in
the West seems counterproductive given
all those good things that are going on
in the background now that doesn't make
what's going on in the West with regards
to political polarization trivial but it
does set it inside a much more positive
context so that's something to keep in
mind
whatever clients need for autonomy /
identity in therapy they would prefer
that which is meaningful and therefore
under the under their control is this
not unhealthy hmm I'm not exactly sure
how to meet what to make of that
question well first of all let's try
whatever clients need for autonomy
identity in therapy that's paramount I
mean in again in my book and in Chapter
nine assume the person that you're
listening to knows something you don't
that's so that you can learn something
maybe because you need to learn
something because like what do you know
in therapy I don't think that if you're
a good therapist you try to take
responsibility for the decisions that
your clients make like you don't take
that decision-making onto yourself
because you have to adopt a position of
radical ignorance no a person is sitting
across from you and this is the true
true of every person you know a person
is sitting across from you and they
don't understand themselves but you
really don't understand them and if
you're a therapist or maybe even if
you're a friend or a partner for that
matter the person wants help and so
something's wrong as far as they are
concerned and there might be some way to
fix it that's your initial starting
place I would say and both you have to
kind of agree on that in a
psychotherapeutic situation well but you
don't know what's wrong you know you
know something's wrong because the
person is upset enough to come and seek
counseling so they want to set their
life right but you have no idea what's
wrong you don't know anything about the
way they think or what what they value
or what their past is or or how or what
they're what they're like
physiologically or what their
temperament is like or or what how
things are going in their relationships
or what their career is like you just
the things you don't know about that
person man it's it's intersectionality
gone mad I can tell you that
and so you got to listen and let the
persons tell you what it is that's wrong
as if you don't know because you don't
know and and so and you have to ask
questions of clarification and but you
always have to remember not only do you
not know what's wrong maybe the person
doesn't know what's wrong it's highly
probable they know that something's
wrong but they don't know exactly what
and they certainly don't know what
caused it and so you got to listen
radically and clarify and ask questions
and make sure you're not confused so
that you do understand and maybe you can
help the person start to understand what
they're talking about or thinking about
just talking in thinking are very much
the same thing and then then well maybe
you get some sense of what's wrong and
maybe some sense of how it came about
god only knows how long that'll take
and then the next thing you have to
figure out is well what would a solution
look like
like even hypothetically what does the
person want and and do they know what
they want and if they don't know what
they want then how can you help them
figure out what they want and how do you
help them figure out what they need and
how do you help them admit to that and
all of that and so that's a boatload of
listening there again you know and it's
the same in every relationship that you
have if you try to foster that person's
development you want to find out well
what's wrong in their lives and you know
but they have to figure that out because
they're the ones that they're the ones
that will have to bear the
responsibility for the decisions so you
don't want to take that onto yourself
it's like well I don't want to tell you
what to do because I don't know what you
should do like we can both agree that
you should move toward what's better for
you and hopefully for the people around
you because we would include that in the
definition of better right because
otherwise it's not sustainable but we
have to talk forever to find out what
that is and you have to be you have to
be very incautious to think that you can
make decisions for someone it's an
arrogant move and it's an ill-advised
move and you shouldn't do it if you're
properly terrified of your errors
because well again I'll repeat
you're not the one that's going to have
to take responsibility for the decisions
they are so it has to be left in their
hands and so so autonomy it's everything
in a clinical practice no that doesn't
mean that you can't help a person
strategize you know you might say well
as you're moving towards some
formulation of the problem you might say
well here's five things that it might be
or here's a list of things that might be
bothering you or you know you can make
suggestions but they can't be baited
suggestions either you can't overweight
the one you hope they'll choose you know
again it's it's incautious a lot of this
I would say I learned well from thinking
about it but also from reading Carl
Rogers I'd really recommend Carl Rogers
you know he was a smart guy when it came
to listening you can really learn a lot
from and and he was also smart in how we
outlined the clients need for autonomous
development and that's the development
of the individual so any update on your
plans to start providing independent
classes or an online university well I'm
working with some young people right now
who are very very smart and the first
thing we're we're gonna build modules by
the looks of things
each module hopefully will stand alone
because then we can test them instead of
launching like a whole University which
seems to be a crazy thing to do we're
gonna make independent modules for
different purposes and then launch them
probably as quasi independent products
let's say to see if there's a demand for
them so the one we're working right now
on right now and I'm not gonna say too
much about it is a competitive writing
module where you'll be able to look at
paragraphs and paragraphs that other
people have written of a variety of
sorts now I don't think I'll tell you
about that I better wait so anyways
we're going to write a competitive
writing module and because one of the
big problems the biggest problems that
has to be solved for any online
university is how do you teach people to
write because you don't want the
university just to be lectures and
multiple-choice tests even though
that could be done with some degree of
reasonable competence mostly what you
want when you educate people is to
educate them not so much into like
factual knowledge but intellectual skill
they have to be able to speak so we'll
need a speaking module and they have to
be able to think and we'll have to
develop exercises that are relevant to
critical thinking writing is a big part
of that so and they have to be able to
read and so those are the big problems
to solve and then the other problem for
an online university is accreditation
obviously we've got some ideas about
that and also what you do with regards
to the social element because that's a
huge part of university is to develop an
intellectual peer group right that's
really an important part in you it's not
going to be easy to replace that online
because you know the relationships that
people make in college often last well
they can last for decades or maybe they
can last a lifetime for that matter but
it's a place where you can eliezer adult
identity and the peers that you pick are
a big part of that of course some of the
peers that you pick when you go to
university should be the great people of
the past that's really what university
is for is to make them in some sense
your peers now that you know that's
pushing it because you have to do a lot
of work before they become peers anyways
we're definitely working on this um the
part of the problem is is that I'm it's
hard it's what's the problem I'm doing
enough other things at the moment so
that finding the time to do this
credibly in addition is one of the major
challenges so I married young and have
had only one sexual partner now I desire
variety but value my marriage and will
not cheat any insight and overcoming
this conflict as a matter of fact yes I
would say get the variety with your
partner you know there's lots of
games you can play to spice up your
sexual life you know buy some lingerie
like buy a hundred pieces you know buy
something sexy for your partner to wear
maybe multiple things buy some buy
whatever you need that you might want to
experiment with you know I mean you have
to introduce that spirit of pretend play
that you had when you were a little kid
into your sexual life and then you have
many partners in the same person and you
put some thought into it you know I mean
sex is something that that sex is a
domain in which expertise can be
developed just like any other domain and
some of that's play and fantasy play and
all of that and some of its sexual
technique and and I guess then the other
thing I would say is take stock of each
other and see if there are things that
you could do in your life that would
make you more attractive to one another
you know those are hard questions
because no one wants to say well you
know I'd be more attracted to my wife
sexually if she just acted xwy and the
same with regards to how a wife's
contemplation of her husband but those
are the real questions man it's like if
your partner isn't acting in a manner
that is sexually attractive then either
there's something wrong with you or
there's something wrong with them and of
course I know people have ill health and
all of that I'm not talking about that
but those harsh judgments that your
sexual attraction makes are also very
useful ways of orienting yourself
towards proper behavior in the world
so I would say any insight and
overcoming this conflict now I desire a
variety but I value my marriage and will
not cheat well admit to the variety that
you want and see to what degree you can
fulfill that within the confines of the
marriage it's also part of coming into
contact with the shadow I would say if
you want to look at it
a union perspective you might have all
sorts of sexual desires that are that
part of you feels should remain taboo
and maybe they should I'm not suggesting
absolute sexually libertine behavior an
old sexuality has to be regulated very
carefully but you might be able to push
yourself with some time and effort and
contemplation and some admission of
fantasy and all of that into domains of
sexual satisfaction that you haven't
achieved before
why do I not discuss religious
fundamentalism more often and more in
depth many people consider you a
religious apologist as a consequence
well it's okay if people consider me a
religious apologist I am a religious
apologist so an apologist is someone who
makes an argument for something and I'm
constantly making arguments for a
religious perspective on life a
religious orientation towards life an
orientation that's centered in in
meaning an orientation that's centered
in desire for all things to thrive
insofar as that's possible a desire for
people to speak the truth and act out
the truth and act responsibility act
responsibly and all of that and I think
that there's something something
transcendently necessary about all of
that and I think it is the antidote to
hell so that that makes me a religious
apologist the fundamentalists I don't
know which fundamentalists you mean if
you mean the Christian fundamentalist
well I understand where they're coming
from you know the Christian Christianity
is an ethical framework above all else
and it's predicated in a story about the
way the world is constituted and and the
story provides the foundation for that
ethic and the ethic unites the community
and gives people direction this is a big
deal now if the story is challenged if
the foundational story is challenged
which is certainly what happened as a
consequence of the rise of empirical
science then the foundation for the
ethic starts to starts to shake and
tremble and that threatens the ethic but
the ethic is what holds people together
and gives them direction so you can't
just lose the ethic so the
fundamentalist Christians are all
short-circuited because they know that
there's something to the ethic and they
understand that the foundation has been
shaken but they don't know what to do
about it
so they insist that the foundation has
not been shaken
and I understand that so I think the way
out of that is to understand that the
truth that govern ethics and the truths
that govern the description of the world
as a material place are not the same
they're not they're not they're not of
the same kind how they're related I'm
not exactly sure but there's no simple
one-to-one relationships you can't
describe the world and then immediately
extract out an ethic it's partly because
there are just too many ways of
describing the world so and this is the
the fundamental point of difference as
far as I can tell between sam harris and
i and hopefully what we'll discuss in
the summer so so that's the christian
fundamentalists and i don't really see
that they're a particularly threatening
group as far as i can tell i mean
they're certainly not in the ascendance
by any stretch of the imagination
they're not involved in any particularly
reprehensible political behavior unless
you count conservatism and it is by no
means obvious that they're even holding
their ground in the culture war so I'm
not very worried about them Islamic
fundamentalism that's a whole different
story but I don't know enough about it
to discuss it intelligently I don't
understand Islam it it it I'm concerned
about its what would you call
compatibility with with the Democratic
West it isn't obvious to me that there
are medium to high functioning Muslim
democracies I suppose turkeys the
closest one but turkeys pretty pretty
shaky at the moment I think that the
failure to separate church and state or
even if we don't call it a failure the
fact that church and state hasn't been
technically separated in Islam makes it
difficult to understand how it's
possible
for Islam and modern Western Democratic
traditions to coexist I don't know how
that can be that gap can be bridged you
could say well with goodwill and let's
let's hope that's the case that doesn't
mean I don't think that Muslims can live
in a modern Western democracy I mean
there are many many kinds of Muslims
just like there are many kinds of Jews
and Christians and so and then there's
the problem of the current proclivity of
the extreme end of the Muslim
fundamentalist world to become to be
very violent in very many ways and so
you know what I'm not a great admirer of
the Saudis to say the least I don't
appreciate their brand of of Wahhabi
Islam and I don't appreciate their
exporting of that view with their petrol
dollars to the rest of the world so I
guess that's what I have to say about
fundamentalists hello dr. Peterson I've
been trying to listen to my conscience
but I can't tell the difference between
fear willful blindness or genuine
conscience well the first thing I would
say about that is it is quite clear that
you are in fact trying to listen to your
conscience because that's probably the
first thing that you discover so that's
a really good question okay
fear well here's a test and you don't
want to do this stupidly
if you think that you should do
something and you think that the reason
you might not be doing it is because
you're afraid then you should do it so
that way you can find out if it's fear
you know I think your question is well
hi do I know my conscience isn't just
masquerading as fear saying well you
shouldn't do that but it's rationalizing
the real issue which is you're afraid of
doing that yeah see here's a reason that
you want to tell the truth and I part I
kind of figured this out when I
looking deeply into the Pinocchio story
you know in Pinocchio as Pinocchio
strives to become real he he has a
conscience to guide him but it's Jiminy
Cricket this insect but jiminy isn't
really a very good conscience he's a bit
dogmatic to begin with dogmatic and
inexperienced and so it's it's not like
the conscience is an unerring guide it's
like a partner in discovery and as you
move forward in your life and you
consult your conscience and you listen
to it then it gets smarter and so do you
but there's a coda there and this is why
I've suggested part of the reason why
I've suggested so frequently in my
lectures and in my book that people try
not to lie you see there are many
systems you have many systems within
let's say that guide you and what one of
those is your capacity for rational
thought and then you have a variety of
emotional systems and motivational
systems and internal dramas and
intuitions and bodily sensations like
lots and lots of and senses lots of
systems that are guiding you and many of
them operate you might say unconsciously
autonomously instinctively implicitly
all of that now you nonetheless you
program them like you feed them content
let's say just like you feed your body
nourishment you feed them content and a
lot of the content that you feed them
pertains directly to your voluntary
thoughts and speech and your actions and
then if you pathologies those by lying
so if you say things that you know not
to be true or you don't say things that
you know to be true when you need to
which is more common and if you act in
ways that you consider that in fact act
in ways you consider reprehensible then
you pathologize all of those autonomous
systems that guide you it's like you're
programming them badly you're building
an AI system inside yourself really and
in some sense that is what you're doing
that has very bad it's very bad training
data and so the output it produces will
be will won't
I do properly and so you don't want to
pathologies your guidance systems it's a
really bad idea so that's why you have
to not lie and maybe that's also why you
have to say what you have to say and you
have to say it clearly as well and you
have to learn how to do that
so that's one of the ways of getting
your conscience straightened out and
then you have to have a dialogue with
your conscience and you might ask it's
like okay well what should I do
or what should should I do this or
should I not do this so let's say you're
thinking should I not do this in the
case of a temptation maybe you have a
chance to develop a new relationship you
know and you're you're excited about it
and apprehensive about it and afraid of
it and you don't know how to sort out
all those feelings and the first thing
is you really have to want to sort them
out that's why you have to orient
yourself to something that's a genuine
up you know that the star above the
horizon you have to really want things
to be straight and you have to have
thought that through and you have to
know what it means for things not to be
straight and really what it means is
that you're headed for hell in one way
or another and if you understand that
it's enough maybe it's enough to scare
you straight you really got to think
that through then you got to think about
how much better it would be if you aimed
up and that really has to kind of
permeate your whole being and so then
you're oriented that way you're oriented
up and you're deciding that it's okay to
try to tell the truth and then you can
start to rely on this dialogue with your
conscience but both of you have to learn
and you're gonna make mistakes along the
way you know that's okay you can say
well I'm gonna try this without being
certain that it's right you can even say
I'm going to say this without being
certain that it's correct like if you're
arguing with your wife or your husband
or your or your sister your father and
you have an idea about what might be
going on you can say look here's my idea
about what's going on who knows what
that idea might be contaminated with
like maybe I'm putting it forward just
because I'm too proud or arrogant or
angry or fearful or whatever that's
possible let's see if we can figure that
out but you can offer tentatively and
have at it that's what you do if it's a
hypothesis right you both have at it and
see if it's an idea that's worthy of of
keeping you do that with your conscience
and then you work move forward there's a
technique in behavioral psychology
called psychotherapy called
collaborative empiricism so let's say
that we you and I have been sitting down
and we decide that you're gonna try
something new this week like maybe
you're agoraphobic and you're having a
hard time in a parking lot and so
getting out of the car and going to the
grocery store so maybe we say well you
know drive to the grocery store and
you're just gonna walk halfway to the
halfway from your car to the door and
that's good enough for like do that
every second day for a week and then
come back and let's talk about it
so that's collaborative empiricism
you're running a little experiment you
think when your conscience is guiding
you towards something you take a
tentative step in that direction and
then you check and see well you know did
what I wanted to have happen occur as an
outcome that's the crucial question
that's the crucial question for
behavioural truth right that's the
pragmatic perspective did what I want to
have happen happen as a consequence of
my framework of interpretation and my
action if the answer is yes then I have
not invalidate it right that's that's
the pragmatic philosophy in a nutshell
and it's it's very very smart so you
have a dialogue with your conscience
that never ends and hopefully it gets
wiser and you get wiser and that's the
dialogue that Jung talked about between
the conscious and the unconscious
between your your fantasy life say the
life that's sort of underneath you is a
conscious being like you the life that's
part of your biological platform the
biological platform that somehow
miraculously gives rise to your
consciousness you have a dialogue with
that we're always in dialogue we're
always in dialogue right with everything
so pursue that
I've watched many hours of your videos
but I don't think I've ever heard you
describe yourself on the big5 model care
to tell us how you rank on each trait
yeah okay well there's a problem because
I know the tests and so it's hard for me
to take them without being well because
I know the tests right so it's hard for
me to take them without the the
ever-present threat of conscious
manipulation I've gone through them with
my family you know to see if we get a
more accurate accurate judgement so I
can tell you on the big 10 scale which
is the understand myself personality
scale I'm pretty enthusiastic I think
its 75th 80th percentile something like
that 99th percentile for assertiveness
so I'm pretty extroverted because those
two together make extraversion and then
with neuroticism that's a hard one
because I've had this problem with
chronic depression that looks like it's
autoimmune related and so I felt a lot
more negative emotion then the typical
person does I would say by a substantial
margin withdrawal well I don't seem to
shy away from things so you know apart
from the fact that I do feel
anticipatory anxiety which i think is
secondary to this depression let's say I
don't seem to shy away from things so I
don't think that temper mentally I'm
particularly high in withdrawal I am
more it's not irritable what's the
what's the next one volatile I'm higher
in volatility than withdrawal by a
substantial margin I can be quite
irritable but again it's hard to
dissociate that from the depression so
anyways my levels of negative emotion
are higher than I would prefer
agreeableness I'm pretty compassionate
pretty high in Compassion's like 75 80th
percentile so you know and but I'm I'm
relatively low in politeness so I think
but not you know not 5th percentile
something like 30th percentile forty
percent off I remember correctly so
that means that huh it means that I'm
blunt enough to hurt people's feelings
now and then and that I really don't
like that because the compassion thing
gets me so conscientiousness I'm
moderately orderly 70 75th percentile
and like 99th percentile for
industriousness and then openness both
of them intellect in 99th percentile for
intellect and then it's like 95th
something like that for openness or
higher so that's where I that's where I
rank so my wife and I found out earlier
in the year and we may not be able to
have children then last month I was
diagnosed with cancer man how do I
combat depression well the first thing
that we should point out here I'm very
sorry to hear about all that that's
that's a lot of tragedy in a very short
period of time man and I'm not gonna
give you any casual advice because but I
maybe I can make some things clearer
the first is you're not depressed you've
had terrible things happen to you that's
not the same thing right I distinguish
between them if a client comes to me and
they say they're feeling very sad and
down and and anxious and worried about
everything and so forth then I kind of
walk through their life do they have
friends do they have a family do they
have a meaningful job is their
educational background appropriate for
their level of intelligence and ability
are they taking care of themselves do
they have something to look forward to
do they use their time outside of work
productively and wisely etc so you think
about those as the dimensions of a good
life there's more or maybe there's fewer
but that's not too bad for a for a quick
and dirty first pass through let's say
those are the dimensions by the way that
you work on if you do the future
authoring program in the self authoring
suite you're asked to think about all
those dimensions and consider what your
life might be like if you optimized
along all of them and so if you if all
of those things are going well for you
and you feel terrible all
the time then you're depressed because
there's there's something wrong with
your emotional regulation you know I
mean maybe you're having an existential
crisis that's a possibility but I mean
let's assume we can't see anything
structurally wrong with your life but
you're feeling terrible then I would say
well you have depression there's
something wrong maybe it's physiological
and people like that in my experience
those are the people who often really
benefit from antidepressants but then
there's other sort of person who who is
in trouble you know they're they their
educational attainment is not what it
should be they don't have a job they
have an alcohol or drug problem they
have a family that's really not
functioning well or they don't have a
family their immediate relationship
intimate relationship is non-existent or
terrible their friends are non-existent
or or or worthless and and destructive
they don't get along with their
relatives they're in poor mental and
physical health you get the picture
that's and they're not feeling good
they're their moods low and they're
anxious that's not depression like it
might be you know but it's a terror but
what that is is a terrible life and
those are different things they needed
to Beach they need to be conceptualized
differently now even if you have a
terrible life an antidepressant might be
able to lift you up enough so that you
can keep fighting let's say assuming
that that's what you're doing but an
antidepressant obviously isn't going to
help isn't going to remove the facts of
your terrible life now you you've got
terrible things happening to you at the
moment and and there's no simple answer
to that I would say you could you could
take a look at chapter 12 in my book 12
rules for life it's a it's called pet a
cat when you encounter one on the street
and in part it's a it's an order by our
autobiographical chapter about how my
wife and I and my family my my son and
daughter and my my extended family as
well dealt with my daughter's extremely
seriously
this while she it's still it still
plagues her to some degree although not
nearly as much as it did she was very
seriously ill when she was a teenager
and it was an ongoing crisis continual
four years of crisis and so the question
is how do you cope with that and the
answer is the first answer is you shrink
your timeframe you know you've had these
especially with regards to your
diagnosis it's like all of a sudden your
future is being thrown completely into
chaos and you don't know how to deal
with that and and who would you do what
you can to stabilize your medical
treatment and to optimize your quality
of life while that's happening a very
complicated thing to do and then I would
say you live for the day you know for
the week maybe maybe it weeks too much
even but for the day just like you get
up in the morning you think I need to do
everything I can to make this day as
meaningful and and rich as I possibly
can and hopefully I will have had a full
day by this evening and then I'll be
able to sleep and then I'll be able to
get up in the morning and say I'm going
to try to make this day as useful and
meaningful and engaging as it can be and
then maybe when you're really sick you
don't have a day you have hours and then
you do the same thing for the hours and
then maybe you do the same thing with
the minutes I would also say you know
you've been through a lot of shock and
it's conceivable that you might need to
talk to someone it's also conceivable
that an antidepressant could help you
you know you've got a lot to deal with
and you might need your nervous system
might need some stabilization with all
that stress and so that's something to
consider antidepressants are also quite
effective as pain medications especially
a drug called cymbalta so that's also
worth knowing because you need to know
about if
- pain medication it's very important in
extreme situations of pain opiates of
course are the drug of choice but you
can use drugs like methylphenidate that
riddle in the ADHD drug you can use them
as adjuncts to to pain medication and
people need to know that because the the
they're basically amphetamines
amphetamines have analgesic properties
but they also keep they also maintain
alertness and so the problem with
opiates is they can be sedating but an
opiate and feta mean combination and
this is for people who are in absolutely
intractable pain by the way that can
increase alertness and help cope with
pain and it's really useful to know what
you might need to cope with pain so I
would say shrink your time horizon and
then
oh thank you okay thanks Tim shrink your
time horizon and then concentrate on the
concentrate on the moment whatever that
moment happens to be might be the next
minute
you know I don't know what else to do
when you're in an extreme situation the
other thing I guess the final thing I
would say with regards to the we may not
have to be able to have children well
you need a plan to address that to the
best that that you can to the best way
that you can and then you have to give
yourself some time to reconsider
we may not be able to have children that
probably takes about a year or a year
and a half to digest so don't be too
hard on yourself if you haven't figured
it out yet it's any major life
transformation like a really major life
transformation I would say takes a
minimum of a year to really adapt you
please give your perspective on why
polyamory is bad for the individual in
society well I think the fundamental
reason is there's a bunch of reasons I
mean the first is societies seem to
function better that is less violently
let's say when there's one woman per man
if there's many women per man there
aren't many women for every man there
are a handful of men let's say a
minority of men a Pareto distribution of
men who have a disproportionate number
of women and a lot of men who have none
and those aren't happy man let's put it
that way they're men who are very likely
to get up to no good very rapidly so
there's that then I would say the women
who let's say a man has many women and
let's say he's a desirable man for that
matter just for the sake of argument if
he has a variety of women then those
women don't have much of him so they
don't get to establish real individual
relationship with him because it's going
to be fragmentary and I don't believe
that that's satisfying for people I
think that what you want as much as you
possibly can is to have people around
you with whom you can weave your life
together over the short term medium term
and long term it adds depth to your life
in a way that almost nothing else can
and so what you do and so I've been
speaking more about permanent
polyamorous relationships you might ask
but what about sequential ones where you
know you're which is in some ways
indiscriminate indiscriminate
indiscriminate um well from just casual
sleeping around
I think the problem with that is that to
sleep around casually is to imply that
sections casual to imply that sex is
casual is to assume implicitly that it
can be divorced from the rest of life
emotional life motivational life values
all of that and you can divorce it but
you pay a big price for that I think the
price you pay is like the virtual it's
it it well the word psychopathic keeps
leaking leaping to mind leaking to mind
yeah good old Freud you have to reduce a
person to the casual pleasure of a
transient sexual interaction in order to
sleep around casually and I think that
once you establish that as a habit with
sex which is a deep a deep experience if
you if you'll do that with sex which is
a deep experience then and you learn how
then what makes you think that won't
transfer to everything else that you do
I don't see how it can fail to so you
know you could say well monogamy isn't a
very good solution it's like well life
is a fatal sexual fatal what is a
sexually transmitted disease with a
hundred percent fatality rate to you
know there's lots of really complex
problems for which we only have the best
answer we can come up with which is not
not a utopian answer but I would say and
I think the evidence supports this as
well that stable monogamy is the best
solution that we know of and it's also
the minimum necessary requirement for
the stability of children so polyamory
it's wrong it's wrong it makes men
violent it increases inequality in in in
the matter that makes things dangerous
it
makes it impossible for women to have a
deep relationship with men it makes it
it facilitates the what would you call
it the transformation of sex into
something casual and then that spills
out into the into the rest of the world
it deprives the people who engage in it
of the opportunity of establishing a
stable long term long term mutually
mutually satisfying it's more than that
mutually beneficial relationship you
know because a good a good marriage the
people in it
gain more than they're more than twice
as good right it it the the the benefits
aren't precisely linear so you lose that
destabilizes the situation for children
there you go man that's a lot of things
that aren't about it that aren't good
that's for sure how do you think altered
state of consciousness or shamanic
experiences can or should be integrated
into modern life and scientific thought
man you guys you're really asking some
tough questions today well the first
thing that we should realize is that
states of altered consciousness are
people have been experimenting with them
forever and god only knows what the
consequence of this I certainly believe
that the old Greek mysteries were
institution induced hallucinogenic
experiences I think that most of the
religious stories that we have are a
consequence of psychedelic experience
most a substantial number of them it
certainly seems to be the case with soma
for example which looks like it was the
fly agaric mushroom the Amanita people
have been using hallucinogenic
substances for a very long time and they
produce very incomprehensible sets of
experiences most recently documented by
the
research teams at Johns Hopkins where
they've shown that if you give people
enough magic mushrooms psilocybin to
induce a mystical experience that you
decrease their death anxiety and fear
when they have cancer diagnosis which is
really something and that a single dose
of mushrooms that produces a mystical
experience has about an 85 percent cure
rate for smoking which is absolutely
beyond comprehension
so the psychedelic substances seem to
open up another plane of existence so to
speak you know and it's it's that part
of experience that's that has an
infinite scope why they do that how they
do that what that means god only knows
god only knows I don't think we
understand psychedelics even a bit I
don't think that they what I don't think
they fit into our current worldview so
how should they be integrated well
you're a fool if you play with
psychedelics no what did Carl Jung say
beware of unearned wisdom that's pretty
damn smart so you don't play with them
if you're inclined to experiment then
you should treat them with respect you
should go into the experience with the
expectation and the desire that your
life will that you will learn something
painful as that's going to be and that
your life will be transformed in a
positive direction and you should pray
to whatever God's you worship that they
don't rip you apart you know and then
maybe you'll be sensible enough to learn
something and you bill to bring it back
from the underworld and you build
integrate it into your life carefully
and you'll be a better person as a
consequence but be careful what you hope
for I don't even have the
conscientiousness to sit down and do
self r3i bought it over a year ago and
haven't opened it what the hell is wrong
with me well lots of things probably
because there's lots of things wrong
with everybody but let's let's not go
right for the jugular you know let's
assume let's
assume that the problem is relatively
simple before we assume that your
character is beyond Salvage which is
also something I would recommend if
you're arguing with your wife or your
husband or your partner you know assume
that their character can be salvaged
it's a good way to start the argument so
I would say why don't you have a smaller
goal you know so if you notice that
you're not doing something I'm not doing
the self authoring program
well maybe it's daunting to you you know
or maybe you're not very disciplined err
or maybe both or maybe six other things
who knows right maybe you're angry that
you spent money on it
it's it could be any number of reasons
maybe you don't want a better life maybe
there are things in your past you don't
want to look into maybe you're afraid of
your personality
maybe you're terrified of the future and
you don't want to think about it god any
of those things can be true but what you
want to do is first notice that you're
not doing it's like oh I'm not doing
this well I must be going about it wrong
well it's sort of the definition of
wrong right if you're trying to do
something and you're not doing it then
you're doing it wrong that's for sure by
your own definition so let's say well if
you're trying to do something difficult
and you're not doing it well you could
beat yourself with a stick until you do
it or you could hire someone else to do
it you know metaphorically speaking or
even maybe really if you want to do it
but the best but barring that the next
best thing is to aim at something lower
obviously your two useless to do the
self authoring program okay
ask yourself sit on the edge of your bed
and say okay I think I'd like to try
this self authoring program is there
some step I could take towards that that
I would do I would say well maybe you
think what I have to do to do it well I
have to find my username and password
then I have to open the web's know I've
turned on my computer I have to look in
my email I have to find my username and
password I have to find the site I have
to open the site then I have to enter
the username and password here and then
I have to start reading it okay so then
you think gotta walk through it like
it's a simulation which of those things
are you unwilling to do you can ask
yourself am I willing to go turn my
computer on yes
am I willing to
open my email yes am I willing to search
through my email for the username and
password well I'm a bit worried about
that because I bought it a year ago I'm
not sure I'm going to be able to find
the username and password okay do you
think you can handle that potential
disappointment and frustration yes I
could do that for 10 minutes okay you
can always buy it again if you look lost
right if you really want to do it's not
that big a deal okay so it looks like
I'll turn on the computer I'll sit down
I'll turn on the computer open my email
I'll look for the username and password
and I'll buy it if I can't find it
that's possibility will you actually do
those things like would you do them
right now
yeah I think I'd do that would you also
put the username and password into the
program itself well then you feel a
little resistance you think well maybe
maybe I do that maybe I wouldn't okay
would you put the username and password
into the program and start reading it's
like nope that's too much it's like okay
then you might think well if I wasn't
such a useless son of a I'd just
sit down and do the whole thing it's
like yeah maybe but you are exactly that
useless kind of son of a and so
you can ask yourself politely what
you're willing to do you might find that
you're willing to open the damn program
and put the username and password in and
like look at the first sentence and
that's a big accomplishment it's like
you could take yourself out for dinner -
dinner for managing that and I'm not
being cynical it's like way to be you
opened it that means you have to get
over your anticipate ory anxiety like
that's a big deal maybe that's enough
for the day if you're fine that you're
not doing something that you know you
should be doing
ask yourself like seriously like you
would ask someone else like you'd ask
someone you care about I'd like you to
ask someone you'd listen to what it is
that you're willing to do you won't
clean up your room okay will you clean
up your closet No will you look in your
closet and like think about some things
that you might clean up if you did it
the next day it's like yes well there
you go
successful negotiation you know you got
it you're not your own slave and you're
not your own tyrant you have to deal
with yourself you have to negotiate with
yourself just like you'd negotiate with
another person so that means you got to
take your
you see the way you find it you want to
accept it and then you have to ask
yourself like you'd ask a really bratty
nine-year-old kid what you might be
willing to do to put another foot
forward and then you have to do it small
as it is in humility because you're so
damn useless that was the best you could
manage it's like well it's better than
nothing so it's good enough and if you
do that every day if you try that every
day or every second day or once a week
for that matter you know if you allow
yourself to genuinely step forward on a
reasonably regular basis you'll actually
move forward you know even that will do
the trick because the benefits will
start to compound so if you're not
hitting what you're aiming at aim lower
move closer to the target until you can
hit it until you can hit it with a
little bit of effort and accept that as
your starting point at least that's good
you found your starting point hooray
hooray you're on the path good for you
you know it really I'm serious about
that my wife says I am like you
ie obsessed by ideas and seldom want to
talk about much else she wants me to ask
if your wife is ever annoyed by it ha ha
no I don't know if she's annoyed by that
I think she's worn out by it you know I
mean I'm amazed that she can she seems
to be able to live with me which is
asking quite a lot of someone because
there's always a lot going on you know I
mean so I don't think she's annoyed by
it
I think she's overwhelmed by it and fair
enough and maybe sometimes she's annoyed
by it too to be obsessed by ideas like
that well that's part of being high in
trade openness especially if you're also
extroverted that's what you like you
know you're high in openness you should
have your wife take they understand my
self test and and you too and then you
can look we're gonna build this couples
report pretty soon that will I'm working
on the paragraphs now the infrastructure
is already in place that will enable
people to compare one another but you
know it sounds like you
extremely high and trade openness
especially on the intellect dimension
and perhaps your wife is lower on that
dimension and so take the test and find
out and then you'll both understand that
it's characterological so you might need
to find people that share your
intellectual predilection if your
interests are more than your wife can
easily and happily let's say tolerate
well hi dr. Peterson I'm a member of the
translators who translate your video
into Chinese how can I speak the truth
and survive in China and protect my
family oh man well the first thing I
would say is god that's a hard question
carefully and carefully and attentively
how can I speak the truth and survive
carefully and attentively I mean I would
say rule number one rule number one
don't suck don't sully your soul that's
like rule number one in life you know
you got to decide what's horrible and
obviously being persecuted for your
opinion is horrible there's no doubt
about that but being unable to being
forced to live in a web of silence and
deception is also horrible I'm not going
to say worse I'm going to say also
horrible so you've got Hobson's choice
there if you're going to do what you can
to tell the truth then do it with
humility and care start within the
confines of your own immediate circle
and don't get arrogant don't get
arrogant don't think you'll get away
with it
you have to be doing it humbly and
carefully push on what you can push on
that you think might change and don't be
contemptuous of small victories and take
care of yourself be careful
you want to maintain yourself while
you're making your attempts so that you
can be along to around to do it for a
long time so see and I guess we could
rephrase the last part of your question
because we could also say how can I
speak anything but the truth and survive
in China and protect my family I do
believe that in the medium to long term
and all things considered you never have
a better bet than telling the truth but
I do say that realizing that there are
places and times where it's relatively
safe to do so and places and times where
it's relatively unsafe to do so and if
you're in China now and for a very long
time you're in a place where it's
relatively unsafe to do so don't take
unnecessary risks don't but don't but
you have every reason to try to keep
your soul and your word intact
my brother committed suicide and I'm
taking care of my sister's kids aged
seven and three until she stables stable
how can I help them cope with the loss
of their uncle
well how do you help kids cope you put a
stable routine together around them so
that they don't have any additional
uncertainty in their life you decide
that you're oriented towards their
future good you know you're gonna decide
that as deeply as you can
are you resentful about having to take
care of them because you might be and
maybe you have your reasons too but I
would scour your soul for that
possibility and see if you can rectify
it by whatever means necessary act
responsibly and reliably and that will
give them faith in adults which is good
because they need some faith and they're
going to be adults so they need to have
some faith in adults play with them
pay attention to them play with them
it's not a bad idea to teach kids how to
come and get a hug you can you can do
that in a pretend play mode you know you
say look let's practice something why
don't you practice prevents pretend that
you need some practice in figuring out
how to ask for what because everybody
needs a hug you sometimes even the 3 and
the 7 year old both should both be able
to play that game and then have them
practice until they get good at it and
then you can play that like every day
for 3 weeks until they're really really
good at it and so that when they're
feeling lonesome they can and then you
tell them look pretend you're feeling
lonesome how do you come and get a hug
and you got to figure that out you
knowing maybe they just come on it and
they look at your feet and they say I
feeling lonesome I really need a hug and
then you know you know you can teach
them to come and get attention from you
when they need it and that's really what
a kid needs is to have someone there to
pay attention when the kid needs it
that's really that's really a good thing
the seven-year-old in particular is
probably gonna wonder if he or she was
the cause of the suicide that
conversation might come up you wanted
wanna watch the kid to see if there's
any evidence that he or she believes
that it's an easy thing for kids to
believe because it actually helps them
make a little bit of sense out of what
happens you know something terrible
happened I lost my dad he went away I
wasn't good enough for him you know
that's really easy easy thing to think
so you might want to keep your eyes open
for the necessity of that conversation
I'm a minority my kids are mixed I
resent the disempowering narrative of
victimhood being handed to them it's
lazy and offensive how to arm them
against it that's a good one well the
first question is you didn't tell me how
old they were so that complicates things
but I would say you better pay attention
to what they're being taught in school
my suggestion to parents is that if your
kids are in a class where they talk
about diversity equity inclusivity
gender white privilege that's not a bad
there's other words too but we'll stick
with those that your kids should be
encouraged to leave the class because
they're not being educated they're being
indoctrinated now that doesn't mean that
there can't be an intelligent discussion
about any one of those topics but when
they come together in a group then
that's a pretty good marker that you're
in the vicinity of a radical leftist
neo-marxist ideology and there's no
excuse for that being foisted on your
children you may have to have a serious
chat with your school with your kids
teachers with the principal you may have
to learn how to form your argument
formulate your arguments against the
practice like if you resent it what are
you gonna do
you're gonna put up with it you're gonna
get angry and take it out on someone
else you're gonna do something stupid
because you're resentful it's like those
are that's likely right are you gonna
swallow it and get weak I mean Jesus
those are dismal options I mean first of
all you might want to find out if all
your resentment is justified you can
talk to someone that you admire and see
if you're just flying off the handle
because maybe you are but if you're not
well if something how is happening that
you really don't like that's a sign that
you have to do something about it
because your being is rebelling against
that constraint so you have to get more
educated you have to get more articulate
you have to get more politically
oriented politically savvy politically
involved you have to talk to people and
make a coalition you have to face down
your chil your children's teacher you
have to come up with a plan for what
happens if when you face them down
nothing changes you have to lay out a
strategy of of Indian War or you have to
live with your resentment and risk
having your children disempowered by the
narrative of victimhood that seems like
a really bad outcome you know if they
see you resisting it actively then you
are right then and there
acting out then the contrary narrative
so if you don't believe that they should
be described as disempowered then you
should act in a manner that indicates
that your convictions have far more
potency than you might believe sam
harris has accused me of sophistry in my
Bible lectures how do you draw the line
between sophistry and a valid reading
well welcome to the universe of literary
criticism seriously right because that's
the real question
I look for patterns you know when I
wrote maps of meaning which is my first
book I laid out a description of the way
that we perceive the world and I wanted
to know if it was an accurate perception
and so I tested it against multiple
levels of analysis and so I wanted to
see well it did it stand up did this
story stand up logically was it in
keeping with what was known at that
point in terms of functional neural
psychology was it in keeping with the
literary tradition did it make sense
from the perspective of mythology
all of these things and my supposition
was that if the interpretation remained
coherent across all those levels of
analysis the probability that that was
spurious was very low just like you can
think about it as akin to the way that
you detect whether or not something's
real using your senses you have five
qualitatively different senses and if
one of them reports the existence of
something that might be faulty and if if
to report the existence of something
maybe even that would be faulty but if
five of them reported then the
probability that there's something there
is starting to become high enough so
that you don't die by relying on it
which is really the fundamental what
would you say at manifestation
indication of of sufficiency you know
Sam's I don't think Sam really accused
me of sophistry precisely what he did
was say like the post modernists say any
text is susceptible to a very large
number of interpretations how do you
know yours is well you could say true
this is where things get complicated
because it depends on what you mean by
true which is another thing that Sam and
I had a had had about you know I act out
my interpretations of the stories that I
read and I
detect their the consequence of that
action in the world and use that as
another means of determining their
validity so acting in this manner the
manner that I believe is appropriate as
a consequence of the way that I've
interpreted come to interpret these
great mythological stories has been of
inestimable and estimable belt in
estimable benefit in my life and I think
it's helped my family a lot my immediate
family and my broader family it's helped
my friends it's helped my students it
seems to be helping the broader
community and it's commensurate with
what I know scientifically and so if
that's sophist tree that isn't sophist
tree because it's just too many points
of contact so so no besides you know
there's other ways of there's other ways
of protecting yourself against sophist
tree too one of the ways you can tell if
you're a social scientist and you've
actually found something is that you're
not happy about it so if you do a data
analysis and you get a result and you
you think oh god that's the last thing I
hope for then that's pretty good
evidence not conclusive obviously that's
pretty good evidence that you've
actually found something real not sort
of like the data for the data that's
been generated by the personality
theorist lately showing that as
societies become more egalitarian the
proclivity of men and women to choose
different occupational routes increases
rather than decreases you can be sure
that whoever made that finding that
isn't what they were hoping for
because that's well first of all who
would hope for that you know it's it's
just there's not an ideology supporting
that as a desirable outcome I mean it
might be a great outcome because it
means that as you make societies more
sociological e-flat say in terms of
opportunity men and women get to choose
what they want and they actually choose
different things and that's okay you
could say that but hardly anyone is so
there's almost no one who's happy when
they find that so often when you
interpret a story let's say you come up
with a self-serving interpretation then
you might
think well I know I'm gonna trust that
because it's self-serving but often if
you I believe is if you take the Union
tack for example through the
mythological material you don't find
what you want you find the opposite of
that you said what's his prime dictum
derived from alchemy in sterk wiliness
invented tor which I'm probably
butchering in terms of pronunciation of
course no one knows because it's Latin
what you most want will be found where
you least want to look well that's
hardly a self-serving interpretation
who's gonna generate that man but that's
what that's the dragon and the gold
right there so you know if your
interpretation makes things more
difficult for you makes things more
challenging requires you to be more
mature requires you to be more
responsible all of those things then I
would also say that that's a testament
to its validity because it's not self
evidently contaminated by impulsive
self-interest so
how is it that society has not learned
from history about the dangers of
socialism Marxism ideology etc after
years how to Marxist get away with it
well let's let's not go with the dangers
of ideology let's go with the dangers of
like to call it radical left-wing
ideology well I think the reason for
this and this also might by the reason
be the reason that there's a strange
thing that the iconography of of social
of communism is still acceptable
socially whereas the iconography of
Nazism isn't now I'm not saying that we
should make the icons of Nazism socially
acceptable either I think that the
communist icons shouldn't be socially
acceptable but they are and there's
probably a reason for that you know now
part of it is that the left has never
taken on the radical left has never
taken responsibility for being on the
same side as the Stalinists and the
Maoists and and the Cambodian murderers
and all of that so that's part of it but
then the next part is I think there's
something deeper I think that you know
inequality is a reality and it's a
reality that cannot be put at the feet
of capitalism or at the feet of human
political structure there's a good book
you guys might want to read this called
the great leveler by Walter shy del and
it's a new book and it's a study of
inequality and one of the things he does
is do an empirical analysis of the
relationship between inequality the Gini
coefficient which is a measure of
inequality and the ideological position
of governments so here's the theory the
hypothesis would be well because the
left wingers are concerned with
inequality if you measured inequality in
left-wing under left-wing governments
and you measured inequality under right
wing governments you'd expect the
reduction in inequality under left-wing
governments and the results are no
difference and so what does that mean it
doesn't mean that left wings are
hypocrites although it might mean that
because people can be hypocrites but
what it means is the problem of
inequality
is so intractable that we don't know of
any appropriate political sociological
or economic solutions that actually work
it's a real catastrophe
now inequality in itself might not be a
bad thing unless it's too extreme it's
extreme when people say start to starve
and then clearly something's you know
it's it's very difficult to I think
everyone would agree that that's a
suboptimal outcome you know we don't
need to get all ideological about that
but some degree of inequality is useful
because well it gives people something
to strive for
it gives them an up right it means I was
thinking about this and sometimes you
actually want people to be rich because
if a new product is introduced into the
market the people there have to be
people around who have substantial tools
of capital to be able to afford it when
it's still novel and then that market
brings the price down for everyone else
and so if everyone had exactly the same
income it would be very difficult to
introduce expensive products into the
market with the hope that their price
would plummet that actually is a big
deal you want large pools of capital
sitting around to so that people can
invest in very very complex things and
you also want large pools of capital to
be the hands of to be in the hands of
private individuals so that there's
competitive
there's forces that are powerful that
are competitive with the government and
with other large organizations so
anyways though back to the Marxists
despite the fact that there are reasons
for inequality and despite the fact that
you can't lay that the fact of
inequality at the feet of capitalism and
despite the fact that capitalism also
appears to be making everyone not
absolutely poor at the same time as it
makes some people very rich they're
still inequality is still painful
reality and no one really likes it
you know I mean you can lord it over
someone I suppose and and extract out
some sense of your moral superiority
because you happen to occupy
a hierarchical position that's higher
and sometimes there's some validity in
that especially if you've earned it
although I would say like glorying in it
is probably a suboptimal outcome it's
still the case that that inequality
violates a moral intuition that everyone
has I think and that's probably the
moral intuitions that lie along the
agreeable axis it's like what wouldn't
it be better if everyone had enough it's
like well who argues with that you know
I mean everyone feels that way and so I
think a thoughtless a thoughtless
compassion makes marxism naively
attractive and I'm not being cynical
about that because there is some utility
and naive agreeableness but
unfortunately the world is a very
complicated place and merely wanting to
be nice about things and wishing that
everything was fair doesn't justify
imposing an equity outcome and
gerrymandering complex economic systems
that will bite you if you mess with them
because your ideological II possessed
I am 46 retired executive wealthy
competent and full of juice who can I
talk to if I want to invest time / money
/ energy in your university people lots
of people are are asking me such things
and it's very much appreciated
it's a weird you know because you'd
think that if people are offering you
time and money that it would be a
straightforward thing to say yes please
climb aboard and help but it's not that
simple
because first of all I don't want to
involve people in something that I can't
be sufficiently committed to it's not
fair to them and it isn't obvious to me
how I can be committed to this yet fully
committed to it and so I'm sort of
playing with it at the level that I can
manage it it's not like it's a game we
have a good product involved or a good
product in in motion at the moment but
I'm not I don't have the wherewithal to
scale at the moment and you know you can
say and people who are developing new
businesses like to do this like let's
say I could come up with a draft
business plan for an online university
and then I can contact people like you
Paul and say look I'm ready to gather
investments and let's say I could raise
twenty million dollars or let's say I
could raise two hundred million dollars
then I have a new problem the problem is
well oh my god I've got all this money
now I have to figure out something to do
with it and that's actually a really big
responsibility not it's not like you
know it's a success catastrophe let's
say it's a first world problem I get all
that but that doesn't mean that it isn't
real so I have to do a lot more thinking
and planning and figure out how to
disperse my time most effectively before
I dare to take on any additional people
who would like to help now once my
organization as is in a place where that
sort of help would be useful then I'll
make a public announcement and I would
be more than happy for people to jump on
board let's say climb on boards
pushing devote resources all of those
things I'd be happy for that to happen
then but I don't want to do it
prematurely because I don't want people
to to risk their valuable resources in
an endeavor that isn't yet solid so all
right so I'm only going to do I think
one more question
I am a sober alcoholic slash drug addict
how can I will find my way back to
belief in a higher power after 10 years
in the empty void of atheism I'm falling
apart well I would say your best bet is
to actually start devoting some some
time to it you know for me I became
convinced of the validity of a religious
viewpoint I think as a consequence of
study read Joseph Campbell read Carl
Jung Jung's hard Campbell's a good
introduction though rich Aurelio de as
well I don't know if you can find your
way back to belief but you might be able
to find your way back to meaningful
engagement and that might that's a
better way of thinking about it you know
the belief thing is a really tricky one
people asked me do you believe in God
and I think I really think how dare you
ask that question I think that's really
what I think but on a more prosaic level
I usually think well I don't know what
you mean by belief I don't know what you
mean by belief and I don't know what you
mean by God these are very cities are
very difficult questions and none of
that self-evident now I would say do I
believe in the crucifixion well
certainly I mean people the crucifixion
how can you not believe in it if you
think symbolically it's like human
beings are we're eternally crucified
right our lives are tragic and they end
in death and we're all betrayed and
we're all betrayed we all experience
betrayal so ok you can't not believe in
the crucifixion do you believe in the
resurrection well people die and are
reborn all the time no they they go
through this is what you're after here
I'm a sober drug and alcohol drug addict
well you know you you had to let
you die when you stop being an addict
and something new be reborn it's like
what's the ultimate significance of that
and how is it tied to the notion of
bodily resurrection well I don't know
what the ultimate significance is but it
does seem to be the pathway through life
to believe I would say you start
believing not by attempting to convince
yourself that the statement there is a
God is true like a fact is true but to
act out the proposition that you should
shoulder your cross and stumble uphill
towards the City of God that's belief
man and you can do that right away
now you might ask well do I have any
guarantee that that has transcendent and
universal significance it's like well
it's not a bad model for emulation so it
has Universal significance in that
regard we each have to shoulder the
tragedy of our existence and stumble
upwards
despite that that has universal
significance does it have significance
outside of life and like it the internal
eternal realm
I wouldn't surprise me if it did I
suppose it depends on what you mean by
the eternal realm they seems to have
significance in the eternal realm of
consciousness it seems to have
unconscious fantasy implicit fantasy and
mythology how is it connected with the
factual world that's a hard question
because the factual world in some sense
divorced itself from that transcendental
world during the development of the
scientific methodology so never the
twain shall meet
it's a methodological issue in part
I think you probably have to draw on the
same forces that enabled you to sober up
and abandon your drug addiction know
something was guiding you forward go
forward again go forward again as if
there is a higher power
that's your manifestation of faith go
forward again as if being is benevolent
and God is good that's the hallmark of
courage and that's a good place to stop
thank you all for showing up today and
and for all the support and and that's
enough for marched March 4th 2018 bye
bye